hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are continuing
with Game three of our match oh it as a
future versus onigiri a story about that
that's that's nothing you've seen on the
board and well so far the the situation
is a Giri won Game two and Alireza won
Game one so the match is a tie and now
we're into Game three
so holidays again with the white pieces
and again he goes for d4 sorry about
that and the giri here goes for knight
to f6
we have c4 g6 Knight to c3 and d5 so not
the Queens gambit declined like in Game
one here we have a nice groom fell
defense we have C capture Sun d5 Knight
captures and E for looking for the D
exchange variation that the main line
with Knight captures B captures and of
course a Bishop to g7 the bishop will be
very strong on this diagonal we have
Bishop to e3 and now c5 challenging in
the center of course you cannot push or
capture because Bishop captures on c3
wins the rook the usual groom felt stuff
rook to see one getting the rook away
from that diagonal and now black just
castles we have Queen to d2 by fuchsia
and now comes a five so asking do you
want to capture and maybe trade Queens
or basically your only other option is
to to advance the pawn in the center so
b5 and the Queen to d6 and this position
has been reached a few dancing and talk
to your games for example funk how habit
against that a job of their game ended
in a draw of on hall and fried Knight to
f3 here and also there is a game Wesley
so against maxime beaugeois grab or
Bishop to d3 was played also ended in a
draw but here we have f3 by allah reza
and it is a new move so as of move 11 we
have a completely new game and it seems
that our razor
brought brought some new poison for the
groom felled a giri of course continues
with f5 he strikes in the center and
Queen to c2 now keeping an eye on that
pawn but also freeing up the D 2 square
for the for the bishop as DF 2 square
will be reserved for the night giri
plans to develop a sari future plans to
develop with the night h3 2 f2 so nice
to be 7 by giri and now Knight to h3 as
planned here algeria advances that the
pawn all the way to a for russia back to
d2 and not nice to be sick so what
some ideas of maybe even capturing here
so nice to f2 and now White's next move
will most likely be c4 so diri prevents
that and pushes see for himself and here
it's not all that all that simple for
Fallujah to complete his development
this Bishop it's unclear how you will
develop it and also not clear how you
will develop this Bishop but future will
play Bishop e2 Castle here and bring all
of his rooks to the B file and try and
play along along the Queen side so
Bishop to e2 and now Bishop to d7
we have castles by future as planned and
now Queen to c7 keeping an eye on this
pawn here and rook the b1 now with the
idea of lifting the rook and bringing
the other rook over to be one as well
we have Knight to c8 and now comes a for
preventing a5 b5 and so on so look to f6
now the rock also be be useful in
defending the Queen side but also if you
start pushing on the King side also will
be useful for for attacking purposes so
we've looked the B for now just
procuring the the roof lift as the other
book is coming to b1 and the Knight to
d6 now as the the Queen freed the d6
square for the knight it's a very good
outpost and the c4 point is again
protected we look F to be one putting
pressure on the b7 pawn and now g5 just
the gear starts his push on the King
side we have Quinta a 2 preparing to
advance the a5 pawn and now comes a rook
to c8 I just continuing development with
a 5 there are sorry not h5 85 just
continuing to advance the pawn on the
Queen side and Geary starts attacking on
the King side with h5 preparing g4 of
course so other days are prevented and
now it would be a bit too too premature
to go for g4 and then after all of the
trades captures captures let's say
captures and captures you will have
Bishop captures and the black cannot
grab e4 pawn because the rook on c8 is
hanging so here Gary just continues with
rook g6 he prepares the g4 push and just
King to f1 getting the King away from
the G file and now a Giri still knows
that it's too early to push this as it's
protected that way too many times
by the by the two pawns by the night by
the bishop so first Bishop to f6
we have been shipped back to d1 and now
but should be back d8 now attacking the
a5 pawn and rook to a-1 defending at
once again and here Gary continues with
rook to b8 the idea being that he knows
that a g4 will at some point end with
the bishop captors on g4 but the bishop
is now here you no longer have to worry
about your route being under attack and
here g4 would actually be a valid you
know a reasonable try because after F
captures and H captures now it's
different you no longer have to worry
about your route being under attack
since the bishop is here and if
something like H captors and g4 then you
have Bishop to h4 also very important
the bishop is no longer on g7 so you
have this and you just remove one of the
the defender of the jeepers and E for
pawns so this would be this would be
very good forgiving however he went rook
to b8 instead and now Russia back to e1
by Fallujah and b5 now Gary once done at
the force an alphas on trade here on the
Queen side we have a captures a captures
and now Queen to be one now putting
pressure on the b-pawn so Queen to b7
not allowing rook to a6 to add another
attacker to the b6 pawn we have looked a
b2 and the now comes up b5 starting to
expand on the Queen side we have rook b2
a2 now preparing to make a nice roof
lift here so Bishop to b6 guarding the
a7 Square rook to a6 and now King to f7
getting the Queen King away from the
back rank rook 1 to a 2 now preparing a
a a queen rook rook battery here and now
rook G to g8 to help out with the
defense of the back rank we have Quinta
a1 and the now comes Queen to c7 so
basically we have a handgun here and now
comes sorry not that but Bishop to e2
Fallujah which waits to see what what
the plan is also if Geary at some point
starts attacking here you will you will
have some pressure on the c4 pawn
already and here we have Bishop back to
see a pushing the rook either back or
forward so rook to e8 by
and now Geary trades rook captures rook
captures and now just Queen the c5 if
the bishop moves you will have a nice
queen - f - checkmate
so Queen to a3 trying to get rid of this
tension forces a well not forces but
offers the Queen trade here and we have
Bishop to d7 just offering not only a
trade of Queens but also to trade rooks
so we encounters with Bishop captures
and now rock a6 future prefers to keep
one pair of the rooks on board and the
King to East 7 now so the bishop can
move the knight will be protected with
night to d1 now trying to activate the
night and rook to b8 giri is ready to
push before and create a passed pawn on
the Queen side we have a bishop to f8
and Giri happily trade Bishop captures
we have King captures and now g4 so you
can either do some trace here and or
just advance the g3 with check so here
we have H for Fallujah doesn't wanna
trade on g4 and now b4 by giri before it
creates a passport either it creates a
pass beep on or if you capture it
creates a pass see point but it might be
a bit too soon as it might be hard to
defend it this c4 pawn so however here
we went for before we have C captures
rook captures and now comes a king to e1
now of course all the resin wants to
bring his King over here to help out
with the defense but also with the
attack against the c4 pawn so g3 by giri
and now rook to e8 here trying to trying
to reach the h5 pawn so bishop the c8
theory of course does not allow that but
now King daddy - now going after the c4
pawn we looked the b6 and now King the
c2 we have looked the b7 and now going
for look the c7 to put the rogue behind
a passed pawn and night beat you with a
double attack on the pawn rook c7 a Giri
defends the point but now rook to a4
with a triple attack and this is what I
meant by before my being a bit too soon
because now c4 point is uh well it's a
liability you don't have a ways of
defending it as its attacked three times
and you cannot defend it three times you
could however push the pawn all the way
to c3 but just might be one and you're
going
lose that Ponder's there is no way to
further defend it so but it is an
interesting move for for example here a
Giri would would have a bishop to h3 try
if you capture the bishop then you
advance this pawn so basically your your
g2 pawn is under attack you have to go
Bishop f1 Bishop captures Bishop
captures and now well it's it's a really
crazy position the bishop no longer
guards at the be five square so you can
go here to guard this pawn and it's just
incredibly crazy no human would ever
play this of course but it did exist in
the position but yeah crazy stuff Bishop
to h3 so everyone for Bishop to d7
he attacked the rook we have looked the
before and now there is no more way to
defend the pawn here so rook to e7
we have Knight captures on c4 Knight
captures so the pond has been grabbed
and Bishop captures on c4 leaving now
fuchsia with the past deep on we have
looked a one trying to go for the g2
pawn and future could defend it but
instead Fallujah goes for some attacking
ideas with rook the b6 and okay Giri
goes for the pawn rook g1 and now rook
to h6 it goes after this point to create
a past H bond Geary grabs the pawn with
check we have King to c3 and here it's
it's important not to do a bad move it's
always important not to do a bad move
but here it's especially important here
I move like a bishop the bishop dat
would have been okay or king to d8 would
have been okay
but the move give replayed rook to f2 is
not okay he creates some threats here
with the G 2 and G 1 bringing your Queen
enter game but it doesn't work giver is
now completely lost so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
idea while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
the mating pattern and for those of you
who just wanna enjoy a show it's d6 with
check and here the problem is if you go
to d8 which definitely is an option you
get a ricochet check and the King has
nowhere to go you have to block with the
bishop and then just Bishop here wins
the game that's that's the easy way out
however giri of course went kink to f/8
not came to d8 and now Fallujah played
rook to g6 and this is how how quickly
Fallujah finds these things in shorter
time formats now the point is guarding
e7 and there's no defense against rook
to g8 mate
whatever you do you're just getting
madder than g8 so here again we tried
rook captures on f3 with Czech future
play Kingdom before and there still is
no defense against rook to g8 mate
whatever you play it's a rook to g8 made
you could of course postpone with rook
the b3 but I'm not even going to comment
on that so really just incredible stuff
so future wins Game three and it's like
in Game one gear it was better for the
entire game and it was Geary who was
pushing but as the time on the clock you
know came lower and lower so did the
future becomes stronger and stronger and
yeah the faster the time format the
deadlier Fallujah is and here finding
finding this idea it's just just
incredible album that's game 3 I do hope
you enjoyed it we're not going to be
showing game 4 as game four ended in a
draw which means future wins the match
and now neither of them can qualify for
the playoffs but they played some very
interesting chess and well I definitely
enjoyed it and I hope you did as well so
yeah future wins that match and we're
gonna see what happens in today's rounds
so once again I would like to thank Abu
Moxie no Roger
Carsten quartz Steven Adkins to increase
entry and the Martin Fisher for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
and thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the Magnus invitational until it
finishes so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day